15 pass completions in a row this will
be his last and it's for the football
game if he can get it
off for the End Zone tipped and he CAU
it touch down holy too step on Jackson
does it again Tammy the mindset of being
back here trying to defend this play is
you how aggressive you're worried about
drawing a penalty but the concentration
the ability to stay with it keep your
eyes focused on the ball throughout the
whole series man it's just unbelievable
man Jack did a marvelous job of tipping
that ball in the direction of the trail
receiver Spencer well this is why they
call it the jump the jump drill right
the Tip Drill is there for the purposes
of extending the opportunity for someone
in a black Jersey to catch that ball and
man Jack was the guy at the top of the
point